You're listening to radio on New
York public radio, public radio,W ,
N, y.
[inaudible].
This is the sound of a what's,
what's this exact title of the piece?
3,580 this is the sound of 3,580
I'm knocking on an object that artists,
Terry Wilcox hopes will be here
long after we all turned to dust.
It's actually fast. The
bedrock, the engineering is,
it will always stay on a 200 mile an
hour wind and maybe like right here,
it's like a nuclear bomb. 30 years ago,
Terry and a few cranes lifted this 40
foot stick and plunged it into this
boulder that we're standing
on, which overlooks the Hudson.
The George Washington
bridge is to our right.
The sculpture reflects the sun like a
mirror and it's made out of two metals,
aluminum on the outside and magnesium.
The pieces, the concept is simple.
One day, many months from now.
These two metals will be one,
but phenomenon is they're mixing together.
How do you mean physically there?
The layers where the metals are touching,
they're physically intermingling,
they're evaporating into each other.
It's a process called diffusion and I've
got to tell you how I heard about it.
Uh,
in 1968 they've opened some minor tomb
and Egypt and they find golden led bars
piled up in the corner.
The tomb was about 5,000 years old
and the bars had become a solid piece.
They think it's happening on an
atomic level, but they're not sure,
but something is making the
metals mix. Maybe just time,
time cracks. Foundations are
roads, borders erases anything.
Man Creates civilization. Art,
particularly art time hates art.
That's why museums have restores.
But here's Terry tried to
collaborate with time. In fact,
he says this piece won't be done
until time takes the aluminum in.
The magnesium infuses them together,
which he calculates will take 1,495 years.
In a sense that is when
this clock will chime.
But until then, all you can
really do is look at it.
So we walk around this piece, oh,
somebody made it up, up on this side.
God bless you. Think they scaled
up there on the bolt. Sure.
Says a bill,
Bill number 98 or something underneath
bill 98 I got to park officials have
slapped on some antique graffiti paint
and some of those paints. The wet
Terry pulls out a pocket
knife and starts to chip away
underneath the paint. We find
more graffiti with the graffiti
and we find a bullet hole.
This is a bullet. Gosh,
somebody shot your art.
That's pretty funny.
Do you think it'll make it
[inaudible] d 3,500 year journey?
I have no idea.
What do you think the world will look
like when this piece is finished?
Do you think any of these buildings that
George Washington Bridge will be there?
These buildings? No.
While I tried to get Terry to philosophize
with me, a group of kids approach
[inaudible] how old are you
guys? 15. Nobody. [inaudible]
how long did it take to, to
Macon? Uh, almost two years.
And when he explains that it won't be
done until these kids and their kids and
72 generations yet to come are all dead
and gone. The reaction is interesting.
How come you guys would touch,
I mean what makes you want to touch it
and grab it, make it seem this real.
They begin to touch the sculpture,
put their palms flat against it.
A few even hug it to not cite you. See,
but understandable and it comes
through helps from the scene impulses.
Terry's art has the graffiti of wanting
to leave something of yourself behind.
Send something of yourself forward
into the future as if to say,
I was here if only furniture
[inaudible].
I'm Chad, I've, I'm rod
and this is radio lab.
Today on our program stories
and conversations with
people who swim upstream and
the river of time,
even though it's an impossible task
and speaking of the impossible,
here's my cohost Robert Krulwich and in
this hour we will be having an argument
with time. We will talk to scientists
who say that time doesn't exist.
We will talk to stubborn people who
argue that, but maybe it exists,
but we're going to pretty much refuse
to notice and we'll hear from a guy who
thinks he can turn time around,
turn it back or defeat
it through sheer will.
Then to get things started. Terry Wilcox,
the guy we just heard from toward the
end of our conversation, I asked him,
what are you afraid of? A
nuclear bomb maybe coming home,
blowing everything away, your sculpture
included and this is what he said,
no, what scares me are the guys out at
Stonybrook. We were just at our dinner,
two of these physicists who
have the government funding
and are trying to create
a universe. I'm not kidding.
You know, they're called like,
you know what happened the last time a
universe is created? And he says, yeah,
they were kind of worried about
that. They may do very well
odd things. It's Stonybrook,
so it's e which is, um,
the location of one of the big super
colliders in the eastern United States at
Brookhaven is called
Robert Krulwich. Yeah.
And so I went on the tour with the tour
guide was named Todd. He was wearing,
as I remember, a Hawaiian shirt and
shorts. Now that it was a little freezing,
but he said, all right, let's, let's,
let me show you around so we can give
you a little tour around our rig.
It's two and a half miles around is
almost the size of the Indy 500 race track
and we drove alongside a tube.
I guess that's what it was.
It was maybe 2025 feet high, kind
of like a tunnel covered with grass,
just driven around the once
and it took her, I don't know,
about 10 15 minutes to
get all the way around.
Now imagine doing that 78,000 times
a second and you're a prototype.
I have never been approached on,
but this does sound a fast and
because this is a collider,
the idea here would be to have the
proton collide or bump into something
with such force in such violence that
for one instant it gets very hot,
hotter than the center of the sun,
as hot as it got near
the instant of creation.
And that's why this is
called the super collider.
The universe one day was there, right?
You can't get before, right.
That's mystery line and that's,
that's what physicists call a singularity.
Everything breaks down and principle.
Unless, unless you're God,
you can't look behind that
because time doesn't even exist.
Times he says to have meaning,
then she want a chip toe
right up to the beginning.
You can't get to the actual
beginning, but to the first instance,
it's the instant after
the beginning, right?
We have a pretty good idea of how the
universe looked up to a few seconds after
the Big Bang and what we're doing here
is we're getting down into thousands of a
second after the big bang.
We're in a huge empty room.
What roughly the size of a blimp
hanger. A blimp hanger small blimp,
and we are at one of the
collision points right now, right?
One of the collision points right now
has only about 45 or 50 feet that way.
That's the place in the collider where
they expect to see these smash ups
between two protons and it's at these
points you should get just for an instant.
The heat and the debris and the chaos.
That's kind of like what the universe
was like at the very beginning of time.
This is the closest to the beginning
of the universe you'll ever get.
Give me a football and you can make
a pass into the early universe.
There's a kind of a funny sense like of
Eden that physicists have about the very
first instance of the universe. Um,
do you think that the beginning was
more beautiful than now? I mean,
now it's pretty nice,
but for some reason I noticed that people
who do what you do love the beginning.
Well, why is that? They
love the questions.
We can explain in a physical sense
using our little mathematical equations.
Almost everything that we see now,
what we try and do is we try and smash
our rocks hard enough to get some glimpse
of what happened then because that's
the untold story. In the beginning,
there was a kind of, um, simple beauty,
very simple.
So one of the motivating thoughts
behind all these questions is,
can I see it before it got complicated?
Is that a part of this? That's,
that's a deep part of it. The
further back you go, you hope,
the simpler the explanations become,
the more beautiful. In some sense,
the modern world is ruled
by complexity and chaos.
The interactions of billions and
billions of particles ending up in this
conversation among other things.
And none of it is really predictable
because it's very, um, it's, it's,
it's complexity of its finest.
So we're looking for the simple
origins of things and then you get the,
um, uh,
in some sense being cast out of Eden by
having all of those simple things coming
up and creating very,
very complex situations.
The world we have now has so many elements
in elementary particles and rules and
forces. It's messy. That's now.
Then it was just nicer.
[inaudible]
moving right along.
Here's a story about a guy whose like
these physicists trying to move backwards
to a simpler time. And his trajectory
is not without its collisions too.
He's not a physicist though. He
thinks about physics. He's an artist.
A painter sells paintings for
thousands and thousands of dollars.
But you might say that David McDermott's
greatest work of art is himself,
his obsessive devotion to living
as if the president never happened.
It's like standing at the shore and
trying to keep the tide from coming in.
It's impossible. But if
you do it fiercely enough,
it's also a little
heroic Swedish producer.
Marcus Lyndon visited David McDermott
at his 19th century home in Ireland
walking into David McDermott's house.
It's like stepping into an old photo.
Brad [inaudible]. You're coming.
I can go warm. We start in front
of the fireplace. Fire Heat.
Get your warm, very pointed.
David wears a green flannel dressing gown,
a white knight cam and a
Fox spur around his neck.
He sort of looks like a small old
lady. When I sit and look into my fire,
I can feel all the people that
went for me and had their fires.
That's the same fire that the
earliest of human beings, right
looking at.
Most people do not need
to live in the present.
Most people don't need
Everybody doesn't need to live in
the present. You living in the past,
I f I find secrets.
I'm to learn his secrets, great things,
useful, really good things. He shows
me one of them. Well, for example,
here's the chamber pot next to the
bed. Yeah, at Blue Porcelain Bedpan.
That's where the urine is.
Through peeing through the night.
He lifts the lid off and shows
me his Pete from last night.
Most people hold their urine through
the night or they break their sleep and
they have to get up and pass through
the house to get to an electrified
bathroom. By the time they get
back to be completely broken,
their sleep patterns, you
can get out of your bed,
you pee and you go back in your bed,
but it's still enough time
to stay in your dream.
He takes me to the bathroom
to empty the bed pants.
I mean here's a bit of something
new. There's very few modern things.
I mean here's something modern.
You're just going to plastic
this cap on the toothpaste.
See Cause I was going to throw
that away just to show you
and I'll throw that away.
Even though the toothpaste
will dry at the top.
You said that is what you've
sacrificed, dry toothpaste,
your the realistic fuel to get
rid of that. How do you cope?
This project seems so huge. It
goes into so, so many details.
So small details like the
toothpaste, the cap being in plastic,
but in the past was not
put together by one person,
wasn't put together by one person and I
am in a position of having to cover all
areas. And you think it's easy to put
that 19th century world back together?
Well, it's not at all. It's very,
very difficult because there's no one
around any any longer who all can do
anything.
I'm saying the past is
so rich and so wealthy.
Think that every year, 19 eight
every year has some music,
manners, science, magic,
culture, architects.
Every year
the contemporary people
want to create more.
They can't even deal with what they have.
Are we going to do the kitchen? Yeah.
When he moved here a couple of years ago,
he replaced everything
new with something old.
So you having fun now this was a whole
modern kitchen and he ripped this out.
He even had the newly
renovated kitchen torn out
out because it was too modern.
There was a modern floor.
I ripped the modern floor up and I found
the old floor used to be a wall here
and the door was,
I made a conscious decision
when I was 13 years old and I
decided that I would never be able
to compete in the modern world.
I listened to my teachers at the school
and they explained what the modern world
was about and they told us that you had
to constantly keep up with the moment,
keep up with the moment,
keep up with the moment or you
would be destroyed by the society.
And I thought to myself, well,
I'll never be able to compete.
I'm still cleaning up. Oh, I'm going to
squish you some more. And so I thought,
well, I'll go backwards.
I'll talk to all the old people.
I learn everything about the
past and I'll go backwards.
I mean, I was already
interested in the past.
I loved history and I was very
interested in what had come before.
I looked at the photograph, the old
photographs of my family and I thought,
these are the same people,
but what a different world.
And I used to call the
past when I was younger,
I used to call it the place. Really.
I called it the place and I
would say I'm going to the place.
And to me the place was
the same as this world,
but everything was was good.
Eventually David stopped playing with
kids his own age and instead stood outside
beer halls and Harris alarms
and talked to old people.
Cause there was a strange feeling I had
when I was around these very old people.
I felt like they knew
something that I did know.
I should tell you something
else that is very interesting,
which has to do with homosexuality and
that is that I didn't see it in the world
that I grew up in and I thought that
homosexuality was something that didn't
exist anymore. I thought that it
was something from the past and it,
and a lot of the books were medical books.
It was all about treating
it like it was a disease.
So I thought it was some old
disease that I had, you know,
that was surfacing and I kept it a
secret. I kept it a secret for you.
Like
David opens up a closet and shows me
these old costumes and party dresses from
his younger days in New
York. See, this is a shirt,
18th century and it's the exact same
shirt that I just saw in a museum that
belong to do or die. And
this is so old that operate.
It's just back in the 1980s
he and his partner, Peter,
were known in the art world as the time
travelers. Did you ever meet anymore?
I knew him. What was he
like? He was a queen,
but one point they were leading a group
of 20 artists trying to recapture life
in the 1920s horses in, in Brooklyn.
We kept horses. We had carriages.
We were riding all upstate
on the road. These mad,
worst carriages. That was
something that was unbelievable.
Now it's only him. Hello. Hello.
Well, oh, it's me and I'm sorry.
And I'm waiting for this money to come
in. You're not desperate, are you David?
Someone money. Okay.
And paying him presents sort of a problem.
An unhappy coalition
between past and present.
Let's not talk because we'll never
get them on the buy side. Right.
He refuses to use credit or the Internet,
so he has to go to the bank to
withdraw the cash in person.
So we buy,
David has lent me an old 19th
century bike without any breaks.
He bikes fast through the busy traffic
streets of Dublin and I end up far behind
him.
We catch up later in the bank tellers
nine so what was the other Russian boats?
You have to withdraw money or, yes,
I have to come to the bank to withdraw
money when I need it because I insist on
doing the banking old fashion.
But don't if you're frustrated now when
you're like right in the middle of a
modern bank with a television going on
and all these modern things surrounding
us. No, it's just the way that
you might have a nightmare.
Yeah, this is, this is a nightmare.
Leaving David's apartment,
going to the bank and then
returning is a little disorienting,
like stepping in and
out of a time capsule,
safe and warm in his bedroom.
He puts more coal on the fire and we
sit down next to each other on the bed
naked. Right now you're take that walk.
So in terms of time, I do believe that
we can travel in time.
I'm not talking to you about actual time,
I'm trying to talk in terms of practical
terms that everyone can participate in
this, I call it time experimentation.
Anyone he cleans can choose their period
in history like watching a merchant
ivory film and then stepping in
water to travel in time. We have
to first except the principle.
The time is here,
has always been here
and always will be here.
In other words,
this moment in time that
we're experiencing has always
been here and always will
be. But this moment in time as
you're listening now on the radio,
on the asthma I voice
comes across a wireless.
This is a permanent fixture
of the universe that I've
always spoken on the radio
and I always will speak on the radio
and you will always be listening and you
always have been listening. But,
but Jake understand that concept.
G understand the concept. I try to
explain to him that I do his idea,
but only in theory. To me, time is linear.
It just is. There is a past,
a present and the future and
you can't jump in between,
but David says that way
of thinking it's a trap.
It's basically a death
trap and you will die.
I love having you. You're,
I'm having so much fun.
We're in the library. The
bookshelves are full of dusty,
yellowed books,
articles for documents and Scipio
photos on one of the shelves,
an old replica of a royal crown.
This is probably something Midi with a
red velvet. Then Jew was on the side.
David tries it on. I
can transform reality.
This house and my man are with you.
I am seducing you into the past.
What do you think? I think it's,
I think it's super interesting.
We could be having still much
fun in this world, you know,
instead of the stupid
world we're living in.
[inaudible] thanks to Swedish
producer Marcus Lyndon.
If you'd like to see pictures of David
McDermott's artwork, check our website,
radiolab.org I'm Jad Abumrad Robert
Krulwich and I will continue in a moment.
Okay. You're listening to radio
lab on New York public radio,
public radio, W and y c
your school more to come.
Hello, this is Abdullah Lenay
from Los Angeles, California.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
jet here with Rama Crow,
which today on Radiolab
stories and conversations
about people who are defining
time swimming upstream in the
river of time, you might say.
And there's an extreme group of people
who say there's no such thing as time who
deny it completely. We heard from
one such person before the break.
Here he is again.
This moment in time that
we're experiencing has always
been here and always will
be. But this moment in time, as
you're listening now on the radio,
this is a permanent fixture of the
universe. That is David McDermott, uh,
an artist, an eccentric one at that.
So he's Kinda easy to write off. Well,
I don't know. You don't have to write
him off because let me write him back on.
Very prominent physicist,
Brian Green, for example,
professor of Mathematics at
Columbia, author of many,
many big fat books about this kind
of stuff. He agrees with them. Well,
here's the thing.
Many of us who have thought about this
have come to the conclusion that indeed
the time that we seem to experience as
a continuous flow is actually not a flow
at all. In other words,
I've always spoken on the radio and
I always will speak on the radio.
Each moment just exist. And you will
always be listening eternally if you will.
And you always have been listening.
It's not that the moment comes to life
at one moment in time that we call the
present and then somehow
drifts away into the past.
Every moment is an is forever.
But understand that concept.
G, understand the concept. That's
too weird. It's a tough idea.
Let me just make it even tougher. Okay.
Imagine if I go and just
hold my breath that moment,
which I just thought up.
I think that moment could last in Brian's
world forever. Have you exhaled yet?
No. And the exhale could last forever.
Somewhere you're always inhaling and
somewhere you will be forever. Exhaling.
A very, very strange notion,
but it's the notion that
some would argue was shared.
My a guy I like to call Albert,
who Dane mentioned to
[inaudible].
Well, it actually starts
when Einstein was a child.
Michio Kaku is professor of physics
at City College in New York.
We read a children's book,
perhaps the most important children's
book ever written in the history of the
human race. It was a book written
by a German guy, Aaron Bernstein,
which asked the question,
what would it be like to outrace a
telegraph message in a telegraph wire?
In other words, to outrace electricity.
This was only the beginning because in
Einstein's head he thought of a different
question. What would it be
like to outrace a light beam?
What would it look like?
According to Einstein mythology,
while normal boys worried
about girls in jobs,
Albert obsessed about light. For years.
Then when he was 26 years old,
finally he was about to go berserk.
He told his friend best Besto that I am
going crazy thinking about this problem
for 10 years. Bern, Switzerland.
That's where he and Besa were living at
the time and working as patent clerk.
The story goes one day,
Einstein's riding the bus to work
any gazes at the giant clock in the
center of town. It's a very famous clock.
Very pretty clock. You've probably seen
pictures. No, lots of famous clock.
Many people have speculated
about that clock,
but we found the letter a
letter again to his friend bess.
I found the letters saying that yes,
he was moving away from that famous
clock tower in Bern, Switzerland,
but putting past bicyclists,
pedestrians and away from that big burn
clock who's insistent ticking seem to
rule the world below and
then he had a thought.
How would that clock look if his little
bus suddenly zoomed off at the speed of
light? You said, no, wait a minute.
If this bus is traveling
at the speed of light,
then light from the clock
will never reach me.
Meaning the light from all the subsequent
ticks on that clock would never catch
up to his eyeballs. Therefore
the clock will be at rest.
The clock will be stationary forever,
but strangely his pocket watch on his
person. If you were to look at that,
it would be ticking just
fine. And then he said, quote,
a storm broke in my mind,
these are his exact words.
A storm broke in my mind and the very
next day he went to his friend Besso and
says, I have solved everything. And
what he said to his friend Beso,
it's very simple but radical idea.
Time beets at different rates,
depending upon how fast you move.
If you go fast, your time slows down.
Not just your clock but your time,
your brain, everything about you,
SLOs, and they've proven this.
They've put clocks and airplanes flow in
airplanes around the world had a clock
in the ground when the
airplane decelerated and landed
and they compared the two
clocks. They were different, a little
different, but they were different.
Now.
Theoretically the difference could be
thousands of years depending on how fast
the plane was traveling,
which raises a paradox.
How can you have two completely
different times and both of them,
according to Einstein, are
equally true, very, very puzzling.
Because if you have a time that's true
for you, right, and I have a time,
it's true for me and they're different
and they're different than what,
what is it? What does time,
what time do we have in common?
[inaudible]
Einstein struggle with this
very question from many, many
years and toward the end of his
life going to miss you. Akaka,
he dropped a hint for how he might've
resolved it in his mind and it was at the
funeral of his best friend Besa. Well,
when vessel had died, Einstein gave half.
What are the most moving
eulogies? He said,
time is an illusion that we who know. No,
there is no distinction between the
past, the present and the future.
It's a very moving quote
and he essentially saying
that in some sense, Bessel,
we'll live forever. Ever since then.
We physicists have been trying to
figure out what did he mean by that?
Maybe Albert Einstein was mourning his
friend here and just didn't want him
dead. And this was just poetry.
Yeah. But more likely it was, um,
it was his guests about
the nature of time,
how to handle the contradiction
of two very different moments,
past moments present. Almost Brian
Greene deals with this in his book,
fabric of the Cosmos.
The moments are they just exist and
somehow it's the human mind in each moment
that makes each moment
seem real. December 31st,
1999 I was at a New Year's party
and to this way of thinking,
I'll always be at that new year's
party because that moment is,
it exists. It's not that
it's somehow goes away.
My mind seems to organize things into
moments that are gone in moments that have
yet to be, but I think that's
my mind. Organizing things.
I don't think that's how the universe
has put together the moments just are,
but look where that leaves us.
That leaves us with everything that
you've done in your life exists already.
Yeah. Everything. Yeah. You're
beginning your middle and your end.
Every moment of time is out there.
You're dead. You're dead somewhere.
You're almost dead somewhere.
Yes. There's no special.
Now you are saying to me
that there is no time,
as I understand it, no time.
Every moment of your life is
already there. Eternally frozen.
Every moment of my life is frozen.
Every moment of my children's life is
frozen and every moment of my great,
great, great, great.
Grandchildren's lives are already there
and frozen and so the universe is a vast
collection of nows now. That's
right. And that that particular, no,
that is just ridiculous. It
just seems, first of all,
it denies so many things.
Denies the poetry of change.
Don't you see what's terribly
unsatisfying about that?
That means you don't have any
options. Yeah. Freewill is a very,
a very difficult question
to answer for a physicist.
Are you happy with this in terms
of free will? I'm very free.
It was a very troubling issue. Well,
you choose tonight to go
to the movies and I say,
let's go to see gone with
the wind. You say, no,
let's go see planets and tire
of attack of the fraternity.
The devils of the sheet levels.
Don't you like to think that you're,
that you have a real choice there?
I've gone to one. I
would love to think it.
Do I know for a fact that the thought
and the impression of freewill is really
real? No, I don't know that
in my heart. I tell you,
I don't really know that. I suspect
it's real because it feels so real,
but there are so many things about the
universe that we thought were real until
we learned that they weren't,
but what I want to know about the future
is that I'm in some control of it.
Yeah. I want to fall in love
because I want to fall in love.
I want to step across the sidewalk in
front of that car because I want to commit
suicide or whatever it is I want to do,
and I don't want the have you or your
pointy headed friends telling me that it's
already there and I'm going to
somehow move from instant, instant,
all preplanned. Well again,
the poetry disappears.
Then the magic disappears and
then most important of all,
my command of myself disappears. Let
me give you an old, the alternative
that reinstates some of the poetry,
some of the freewill that you're
longing for, and I got to,
I long for the same thing and
I do. I absolutely do. And I,
and I feel like I have free will. I have,
I feel like I have the ability
to choose my next word.
I feel like that can do that. Do I
really have that freedom? I don't know.
I think are doing. Perhaps that's
enough. Just the illusion of the freedom.
But anyway, let me paint a alternative,
but highly related scenario.
In quantum theory,
some have suggested the so-called many
worlds interpretation that the universe
is not a single entity.
There are many universes.
We call them parallel universes.
Each of the choices that you make
is born out in one of these copies.
All right, I'll give it to
you. We're in a restaurant.
I am sitting there and it's
time for dessert. The waiter
approaches and he says,
would you like chocolate ice cream
or vanilla? I think this over.
If I choose vanilla
from then on, I'm in the Vanilla
Universe, but if I choose chocolate,
I'm in the chocolate units, so all the
consequences that flow from my vanilla,
I say vanilla and then somebody named
Bonilla happens to come in and I fall in
love with vanilla and I married
vanilla. We have a lovely vanilla ethos,
but if I choose chocolate,
I go into a Mocha thing and I suddenly
am living in the Caribbean. Right.
All right, so this is a real
divider for me. Don't you see that?
This is like dumb. I mean like
it's an easy, when you say dumb,
can you just be more precise? There
are many criticisms of this picture,
but I want to know which
one you have in mind.
The reason I think it's done is is
because it's like a pat solution.
Like you say, okay, since I can't
get you free will the old way.
What I'll do is I'll give you a lot
of universes so you can have it all.
You can have the chocolate university,
you can have the vanilla university.
A key thing is a key thing
is this proposal which was
put forward in about 1957
by a guy named Hugh Everett and then
developed by many people price to whit and
so on was not put forward in order to
restore anything to do with free will.
These physicists, very,
very high powered create a physicist
were studying quantum mechanics and they
came to a puzzle.
If quantum theory says
there's a 30% chance you're
going to pick the vanilla ice
cream and say a 30% chance that you're
going to pick the chocolate ice cream and
say a 40% chance that you're
going to pick pistachio,
and yet when we look at the
world and we look at what you do,
you seem to choose one or the other.
Where do the other possibilities that
quantum theory said could happen?
Where do they go? Do they just
disappear? Did they disappear? Well,
that is very hard to realize in the
actual structure of quantum theory itself.
You mean that physicists, when they
order chocolate, do they then think,
had I chosen vanilla my whole
life could have been? No.
They don't think that
they say to themselves,
at least the fellows that believe say,
hmm, I chose Vanilla in this world,
but there's another version of
me that's now eating chocolate.
You guys are weird.
Well, hello there.
My,
I've been alone
now to be fair to Brian at a quantum
restaurant at a kosher quantum restaurant.
That's really quantum. Are
they really such things?
I think for the purpose of this
argument, they will be okay.
Waiters will deliver you closed lids
of ice cream and they won't tell you
whether there's chocolate even
though they both in there.
They'll say mysteriously, I'm
usually, I think I'll have chocolate.
Chocolate pops into existence
and vanilla goes away. So why?
That's why quantum scientist wonder where
things went because there's a mystery
here, but that's another story. I'm
sure your head is spinning. Yes,
it is fitting. My head is spinning. D,
do you feel it sometimes seems that
Einstein was the point at which physics
broke away from common sense?
Everything you've just told
me is utterly fascinating.
And at the same time I really confusing.
How do you live your
life with knowing him?
Do you compartmentalize everything
that you study in this office?
Well, you know, um, late at night, um,
I think about these things
and it gives you the willies.
I do think about the fact that
there's an alternate meal out there.
A clone of me except by chose
totally different life paths and uh,
yeah, I can write down the equations,
the equations for these alternate
universities where I exist in another
universe. Perhaps Elvis
Presley's still alive.
A man. And funny,
I could ask that question.
Is Elvis Presley alive and
what are these universities?
At that point I had to
stop. I have to stop.
If this strikes you as a little too weird
that there could be a bazillion Mishi
was out there in the world in various
universities doing various things all at
once. One of them could be talking to me,
but one of them could be
talking simultaneously to, okay.
One of them might be impersonating.
I was cause remember it an
infinite number of universities,
you can do an infinite number of things
that we should keep in mind.
This is still just speculation.
And as particle physicists,
Lisa Randall likes to say,
I mean there's a big difference
between physics and philosophy.
You let that go away, you
sort of lost. Um, the,
the great thing that is
there in terms of physics,
which is the ability to actually make
testable predictions about the world.
Oh wait, oh wait a second. If she wants
a testable prediction about the world,
there have been experiments and real
science experiments I can thinking of one
that was done in 1960 and was repeated
over and over since then that examined
freewill and time in a very
interesting way. And by the way,
this experiment created an uproar,
especially among philosophers
because it's kind of a doozy.
It involves finger wiggling. So can
I have a little mood music please?
[inaudible]
the scientists invited a group of people
to come to the lab and sit down and
have their brains monitored.
And then according to the
neurologist vs Ramachandran,
they turned to their
subjects and they said,
at any time you wish wiggle your finger.
That sounds easy enough. Remember,
by the way, that to wiggle
your finger takes two steps. First
you have to decide to wiggle.
Then you wiggle. So you have to think
it before you do it, which takes what?
Like a 10th of our millions of a second
or something? Yeah, very short time.
So you sit there and you think,
okay, now I'm going to wiggle.
However, when we did this experiment,
I may look back at the graphs of all
the brains of the people who did this.
What they found was your sensation that
you asked your finger to your finger to
wiggle your sensation. The will came
a second after the brain kicked in.
If you looked at my brain waves
when I was wiggling my finger jet,
here's what you'd see first. You'd
see my brain getting ready to wiggle.
There's a spike
[inaudible]
or a blip is Ramachandra would
say, that's my brain getting ready.
And then second, you'd get a
second spike showing the wiggle.
So there's a blip.
Okay.
For Getting Ready. Yeah. And
then there's a blip for wiggle.
Now logic would tell you the way this
should go is first I decide to wiggle,
then my brain gets ready and then my brain
wiggles. Right? But when they looked,
what actually happens is before I decide
to wiggle before my brain mysteriously
is already getting ready. You,
even though you think you're
willing the brain to do something,
it's your brain that's willing you
to will. It's thinking ahead of you.
And then your so called thinking
is a postdoc. Rationalization.
So I don't have any free will.
You don't have any free both.
That was the implication that
the philosophers came by.
Why can't you just say
that? The brain is a,
does a little bit of stuff before
you aware of it. It just always does.
It just takes a three quarters
of a second to get going.
This is fine for everything except the
awareness or winning cause will by its
very nature is a feeling
that you are doing it.
So imagine says Dr Ramachandran that
you could, and it hasn't happened yet,
but you could see your brainwaves in real
time on a screen right in front of you
in real time. Yes. No, the question is
what's going to happen? Okay. I say,
look,
I want you to move your finger anytime
you choose in the next three minutes.
So you're sitting there thinking
about nothing in particular.
Mm hmm.
Wait, whoa. I thought the wiggle was
going to be just proceeded by the blip,
but it was like a whole
second before that. No,
your brain is way ahead
of you on this thing.
Let's just to listen to this
again cause it's a long pause.
[inaudible]
we go. Then you say that
blip was controlling me.
Why the hell is free will even a
simple thing like mowing my finger,
I can't do on my own without the
blood telling me ahead of time.
You either going to say
the blips controlling me or
you're going to say the blip
has ESP,
but this gives you an experimental
handle on something as a lose of his free
will.
[inaudible]
time here betrays fee will because your
brain acted I head of your decision to
act. You have no idea who's acting.
It's just one of those weird,
I don't think they've
ever resolved this either.
Yeah, I dunno. Yeah. This,
that's me very much in control of the
pen in my hand. Beating it in the table.
I just did that. Yeah. But if I
were to put a graph in front of you,
showing you your brain and there was
a piece of your brain that anticipated
that, and then what would
you say? I would say that I'm
their wrong. I guess. I don't know
if me, cause we have to take a break now.
If we go to our fingers goodbye and we
would think that we would think that it
was our choice to legal.
But the real question we should
ask is who's who he clean?
You're two or two. You're
the same. Two to radio lab.
This is Dale Richards in Kent, Ohio.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
chat here with Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
We've been looking at the concept of
time this hour, fighting against it,
defining it and denying it.
Our last story, however,
Isabelle making peace with our
place in the history of time.
It comes to us from producer Ben
Adair and it unfolds in a very,
very old place. The Mojave desert.
These are old mining roads.
Once upon a time hopeful and men and
women looked for outcroppings of quartz
iron, copper and when they found them.
This is public land administered by
the bureau of land management but BLM.
They filed a claim and Doug follow e
p 15 and you'll see the signs for the
borough Schmidt tunnel between the
years 1906 and 1938 a lone minor dug and
blasted eight 2087 foot hole
straight through a granite mountain.
That tunnel was blocked.
His name is Burro Schmidt and he
first filed this claim in 1904 today.
David airs digs here. He gets
tours of Barista tunnel. He says,
miners still roam news hills
and the way he got his
name Burro, Schmidt,
he always had two boroughs
with them, Jack and Jenny.
And of course once they died, a burrow
didn't waste anything. So we ate them.
And borough died in
1954. They had his, uh,
funeral right in front of the
tunnel entrance and a 1963,
Tony and her husband came
up for the next 40 years.
She was up here and, uh,
Tony died up here on her bed inside her
house like she wanted to at the age of
95. That old woman is legendary.
She was scared of nothing when she
died up here. She didn't die alone.
I was by her side and our granddaughter
from Vermont was here too. And uh,
but she never backed down from a fight.
Uh, there was once when she was 75,
she had a fist fight with a guy right
in front of her house and she won the
fight. She cheated, but she
wanted to fight. What'd you do?
She had a role and nickels
in her fist. But, uh, no,
she never backed down from any fight.
How long do you think you're
going to stay up here?
I gotta be out the 29th of
this month. Really? Yeah.
The BLM is going to take
over the place and run it.
They're gonna say burrows cabin. They're
gonna Save Tony's house over there.
Everything else is going to
be bulldozed and cleared out,
which is unfortunate because they're
going to change the way history looks.
This is basically the camp
that an old woman built up.
It's not supposed to be Disneyland. If
you want Disneyland, that's an Anaheim.
If you want a desert camp. This
is just a way some of them look.
So this has been going on for a
long time, this BLM stuff? Uh, yeah,
quite awhile. Uh, Tony, since
she lived here for so long,
they didn't bother her. Uh, they
just basically waited for her to die.
She expected me to save
the place and I was,
I promised her that she would die on
her bed up here like she wanted to.
I kept that promise. The second promise
I wasn't able to keep up. You know,
I tried. In fact, a lot of people tried,
Jeez, I'm never going to stop missing
her. Never, you know, she was,
there was no one else like her.
Mm,
David EHRs is gone now.
But before he left,
he looked over his ramshackle
camp and told me, don't be sad.
The days of the desert
rat have already passed.
What's here is just a corpse.
[inaudible]
um,
people who spend time in then we'll have
you start thinking differently about
space. Huge stretches
of land without a house,
a telephone pole or high tension wire.
You can close your eyes while sliding
between mountain ranges at 80 or a hundred
miles an hour. I'd love to drive
death valley and a really fast car.
A friend of mine said he really, really
fast car.
The valley is the best known
part of the Mojave desert.
Dropping down onto the
valley floor from the West.
You see huge salt flats below
you. Reddish Brown mountains.
Peak in the distance in between them.
Huge washes of boulder rubble and
sand flow into death valley like a dam
bursting in extreme slow motion.
The range is rarely in death
valley. When I was there,
a light drizzle caused a flash flood
in mosaic canyon where sculpted marble
walls dropped down hundreds of
feet to it. Teeny tiny stream bed.
The string fans out here and Mosaic
Canyon is a temple of reds and whites
arguing domes and voluptuous curves
there at sinks down deep into the rock
making hard stone look. Supple.
Death valley exists in geologic time.
The oldest rocks at bad water
or 1.8 billion years old.
Standing here watching the stream flow,
I started thinking about that Mars
rover. I thought about my girlfriend,
my family and politics.
Mosaic Canyon sinks a
tiny bit deeper each year.
100 human empires will rise and fall in
the time it takes death valley to notice
our passing.
Yeah.
[inaudible] hell one each
year can serve as a vacation.
Everybody from the
reality of another view.
[inaudible]
are we one 90 bisects death
valley used to the park.
It ends in Death Valley junction.
A former ghost town revived 36 years ago
when Marta Beckett reopened the Armour
Gosa Opera House. This is the second
season of her show. The masquerade
[inaudible]. Someone else
[inaudible]
Myrna Beckett is a dancer.
She spent the first half of her life on
stage in New York in her early forties
she found this abandoned
theater. She patched the roof,
painted an audience on the
walls, so the curtains,
the costumes wrote the
script and choreographed the
dance. Saturday night sell
well, are there like many musicals,
if you want to call one we did before.
This was called the doll
maker. Bought a doll shop.
You can go and buy the
perfect companion for life.
Not have to bother with a real
one is quite controversial.
I made a few enemies out of it,
like the doll maker. The masquerade
asks questions about identity,
who we want to be versus
who we actually are,
and it sort of summarizes why a lot
of people move out to the desert.
There's a freedom here
in New York. It's like trying to
paint on a canvas that's already okay
painted. Not out here.
[inaudible]
nobody really knows who was first
though. Anybody can tell you why.
As city real estate spiraled
out of control. Artists,
musicians and old hippies
have migrated here.
The extreme south end of the Mojave
desert tucked away around pioneer town,
Joshua tree and Yucca valley are
free spirits living off their art.
Of course,
the land grab is the cynics point of
view and it's easy to feel jaded around
young kids singing in old men. Drumming.
Urban sophistication is when you
refuse a strangers hug or laugh.
No questions asked,
but those who've dropped their cynicism
will tell you this is a place of
optimism and hope it's genuine.
The woman cooking brought
extra burgers to share.
The climbers are back with their
instruments. Looking for a company man,
no experience necessary the Indians
thing because it feels good.
You can feel good too if
you want. It's your choice.
Uh, my name is sunny two feathers. I'm
27 years old and I'm from chem sac,
Saskatchewan, Canada.
Describe for me what we're looking at
right here and tell me how you see that
versus maybe how other people see it.
Well, yeah. Right now.
What I'm looking at is a beautiful desert
paradise with folders that has symbols
of hands and symbols of people,
of animals and spirits. See You,
beautiful in front of me,
tall reaching for the sky,
reaching the pray to the Creator
and the it looks all
glimmering in the moonlight.
When people are out here,
they all their stress and worries and
the problems go away. Their anxieties,
fears just totally leaves
them when they come out here,
but it's just so hard
with the society now.
We don't know how to escape this
control that they have over us,
but when we're here,
the moment it's just happy and
everything blows away with the wind.
Some was bad and some was good.
Some in the best thing could.
Some have even try Andy's
my Trump mind and a cane
and
they're aware of where I'm banned.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
In 1989 a sculptor named Noah Purifoy
bought a ranch on the flats north of Yucca
Valley.
Periphery is probably best known for
founding the watts towers art center in
1964 but he also made huge assemblage
sculptures from lost and found desert
objects. Some are serious
but most are whimsical,
all are in pretty bad shape.
His first few years out here,
periphery fought the elements,
but later he incorporated their
effects of sculpture is never done.
He surmised after he built it,
the weather continued the process.
I went out to talk to periphery, but
I was a day late when I got there.
I phoned his assistant and she told me
that he'd passed away the morning before
she was devastated. After hanging
up, I walked around his garden.
I wandered down a sculpture,
built like a hallway filled
with old calculators,
cash registers and boards
with rusty nails sticking out.
I stood there thinking about this man
who had just died and I started thinking
about those old miners,
their desert way of life.
I thought about Martin Beckett singing
her operas for 36 years and I thought
about death valley.
The sense of time there that threatens
to make everything we do here absolutely
irrelevant. Everything I've thought
about these sculptures decaying,
the minors disappearing, all the
artists dying and every last one of us,
the entire human race turning the dust
blowing around the Mojave desert and the
wind
[inaudible]
Noah Purifoy once said that
after he finished his sculptures,
they take on a life of their own. I'm
going to hope he's right about that.
I really need to believe it's true.
[inaudible]
Ben and Jerry's is a producer for KPCC
radio and he has his own show out in
California called Pacific drift and we
would be very curious to hear what you
think of our show. We have
an email address, radio
lab@wnyc.org radio lab is one word and
anything you heard you can hear again at
radio lab. Dot Borg. Come chat out. Boom,
rod and I'm Robert Krulwich
and we are signing off.